she was like she would have been like I
was so sorry I brought him into this
world I didn't know how to control him
he's a demon so honest
[Music]
got another Revenge story I think Nick
you're gonna like this one is this in
India again no it's not in Tejas
Texas Revenge thank you there's dumb
[__] there too there's the [__]
everywhere apparently I I for some
reason I just feel like this side of the
the room is going to resonate with this
type of Revenge oh boy oh yeah police in
San Antonio Texas said a man
killed another man who allegedly stole
his truck after tracking the thief with
an Apple Air Attack
Bart's excited I don't care I'm not
excited at all even in Texas can you can
you still do that [__] you can't do that
the Apple Air tags are illegal there no
they're outlined
or an Android
what's up what's up what's the Apple Air
Attack so Apple air attacks one of those
circular little oh actually it's like a
tile you know tile it's not like a wow
my air phone so you see this thing right
here if that's a fight my air phone
right it's kind of like not airful yeah
oh it's your keys yeah well or you could
put up you can put it in your wallet so
they have like those little like holders
because it's a little circle thing
um and I think I think correct me if I'm
wrong with somebody else knows because
of the amount of iPhones or Apple
products that are just constantly in
circulation what happens is this kind of
like always sends out like almost like a
grid ping wow so even if you're like
hella far away or it's not connected to
Internet or anything like that because
there are so many things that like
overall create like a data grid of
locations it pulses yeah
and it goes bigger back so if I ever
like um if I walk away from this with my
phone far enough I'll get a little
notification that says like oh that's so
cool item no longer detected in your
radius or whatever so he left it in his
car people put on their dogs their car
their kids I'm gonna put one on my dog
yep are these pretty new
not not super new but uh it's kind of
all the way to the party 23andMe it's
been around for at least five years yeah
it's like 23andMe where the more people
that have them or use them to keep track
of your keys or wallet or nothing I got
this bad boy right here
how many can you have pack comes with
like four when you buy them one for
every car and one for your lady yeah
yeah I got to keep on your lady's butt
yeah wait does the battery run out all
fast like tiles no not really I mean I
haven't charged these because Tyler tile
is really good to use but then that [__]
like it's it's like the light bulb thing
they just like make them weak so they
have to buy another one [__] cars I
don't know what the actual life capacity
or spin on these is but you gotta charge
them so far it's been solid where's the
part supposed to make me angry I'm I
said you might resonate with these I
didn't say you were gonna get angry
resonate positive stolen's truck dude so
basically so what did he do he kicked
down a door say give him back my truck
Texas style well the alleged Thief
apparently wasn't aware that the vehicle
was being tracked via an Apple Air tag
um good for him and uh police said that
the truck's owner used the Air Attack to
track the vehicle nearly 20 miles from
where it was 20 miles again wow that's
like a 15 minute drive no on the freeway
yeah
okay and then authorities found several
bullet casings and two cars with their
Windows shot out so apparently what had
happened was this guy took the law into
his own hands you know what I mean ends
up going to find where the Apple Air
Attack was [__] tracking the car went
there and then blasted him yeah but he
broke his own truck to do it is he in
trouble or is Texas that's cool
because that's kind of cool
I like that huh Finders Keepers losers
weepers I don't think it's cool at all I
like it if someone
[__] with you then now you're the police
that's kind of cool you have a bad well
Texas has the most like laws that are in
favor of somebody like property rights
yeah they got like castles they got like
good ones right like they got real good
ones but this you is even that's too far
right I don't know if you can like I
don't like someone if they step on your
property you technically could just
shoot them I don't know if they take
your goods and run 20 miles I don't know
you could follow them because then
that's kind of like stalking and
assassinating it's definitely not
encouraged for sure and he's technically
probably going to get in trouble for for
this but
um there's obviously people like that
you know via social media and stuff like
that that are very like well what do you
expect like if you call the cops you
know what I mean you're not going to get
your car back is it does it say he was
arrested at all that guy
um it says you got the middle level it
is considered a suspect and was arrested
he'll be the officials are determining
if he's going to be charged in the face
but what if his pink slip matches his
eye ID and then they're like yeah he
kind of stole the truck
because you know another thing you can
do is if you don't like a guy you let
him borrow your car and then you just
kill his ass and say he stole my truck
yeah that's one good way and that's
probably why you can't assassinate
people that just steal your things you
know
it's just uh hard to prove that they
stole it I I am also an impression that
like even if you you know you get robbed
you get your car stolen or something
like that 99 of the time out here you
just find it like months later it's just
I mean you get a nice police shrug yeah
you're gonna yeah you're gonna please
shrug that's it you know what I mean so
it's kind of like what what do you do
when my that's all sad when my phone got
jacked like back in the day and then um
the cop was like yeah we'll go over and
get it yeah right and then we we went
together to uh where it was pinging at
and then we end up at this like house in
Huntington Park and then the cop
instantly like recognized it and he was
like you're not getting your phone back
man like that's a that's a house they
always he goes it's not worth it whoa
because he goes we'll knock on the door
and we'll see what happens but if they
say it's not here it's just just
consider it gone so he went up to the
door what the [__] it's like this it's
like where's the SWAT team with a
[__] battering ram where's the
helicopter go for a phone it was like
this
us house that would be nice
um we go up we knock on the door there's
like this house had a shitload of
cameras and this is like maybe like
eight years ago it's like a neighborhood
drug lord or something could be he
didn't say but it's like I had tons of
cameras we knock on it
um somebody like opens it a crack it was
like some girl and then he was like yeah
we gotta um I got a stolen I'm looking
for a stolen phone and they were like
they just shook their head and they
closed the door and that's all you have
to do the cop is like it's probably
better just to get a new phone than bug
these people because then they'll just
know you
yeah everything he was like it's not
worth getting like just get a new phone
he's a cop well I think the cop is
saying he's gonna die he's saying like
he goes away so it's not there and then
the cops just like hey I need that phone
because there's a ping here you know
what I mean but that doesn't matter they
could just say so what like it don't
matter cops don't cop anymore man you
got a cop more than the cop you do
because it doesn't even like even years
later so like cut now to last year a guy
a guy
and he pinged it to the homeless tent
one block away and the cops came with
him to that tent and they were like hey
we got a phone picking in this tent
homeless guy just went like this the cop
goes yeah
there's nothing they can do dude this is
the ultimate way to stop cops I'm
telling you that police shrug is like
freaking dude because we
a cop would just grab your ass and just
take it yeah they'll just start emptying
yeah don't just shake you down and it
falls on the ground they're like oh
looks like you stole it they might still
do that if the dude's not homeless or if
they're not in California I think it's
again it's like that's the theme I think
honestly like if it was me and I stole
the phone I was walking around they
would for sure shake me down but because
it's a homeless guy in the tent the cops
like extra I can't really they're like
super connected absolutely wow there's
absolutely even less they can do because
it's like then it just looks like a
punch down oh [__] and then everyone's
afraid of um being like caught for
harassment and all that huh yeah they're
the politics protected that too much but
it was literally in the tent
the Ping the dude was calling his phone
and he's like it's right [__] there
[Laughter]
that's my ringback tone it's in his hand
and then the bum's like I don't know
where it went yeah there was just
nothing they could do man
so at that point are you allowed to
maybe like that tent on fire or
something
I think Texas Maybe
it's because then because then if it's
on fire you go oh no I need to get a
bucket and then you you [__] take out
the fire to help me help you clean up
yeah and then you're like oh this is so
[__] up let me help you you know then
you a bucket accident oh my God you
found my phone
stolen properties like in Cali is just
it's gone yeah it's gone it's gone it is
unless you want to like up the stakes
and cause a bigger crime it's like just
get a new thing is that what the like
the public is saying some are for him
because they're like it's so hard yeah
because they're like what other choice
do you have you know I mean the
authorities stop at some sort of
invisible red tape you know what I mean
but you know some would say is it worth
a life though and then other would say
yeah I would say it is I would say to
the person who stole it was your choice
to lose your life for it yeah I wouldn't
because like
back then when I committed crimes and I
broke into homes and things like that
allegedly if if I got shot if I got hurt
I'm just like I'd be like I deserved it
a thousand percent I Played with Fire
you know what I mean like and in other
people that are if if they were like no
you know you shouldn't lose your life
for stealing and I'm like yes I should
that's the consequence if I hop into
someone's fence and they're dog [__]
bit me my dick falls off and they kill
me that's my that's mine yeah if that
happened to you would it would your mom
tell the news he was such a good boy
she was like she would have been like I
was so sorry I brought him into this
world
I didn't know how to control him
he's a demon so honest he was a straight
A student there is no honor to the
family I will kill myself now that's
what my mom would do [__] that kid
Joel [__] sucks
[Music]